for the rangers they're going up against
the right-hander justin dunn a guy that
they have seen
conor falef has six deals and nine tries
this season
takes off again
pitches outside the throw to second the
tag by france and they got him he came
off the bag
ty france playing third he's going to
cover and he does the right thing he
keeps the tag on him it looks like
almost a pop-up slide his foot comes off
the base right there
jordan lyles up on the mound today for
the texas rangers mariners have seen him
before this year i've seen him a couple
of times it's been a tough year for him
the five starts he's one and three but
at eight five nine era back-to-back
walks
and not the start that lyles was hoping
for this afternoon a very legitimate
rookie of the year candidate but he
might have just rolled into a double
play solax returned to first in time and
they turned the 6-4-3
and that's a huge break for lyles seeger
gets a chance to rest his legs a little
bit today d.h
slog deep out towards the gap right
center field and just over the wall for
a home run
seeger's sixth
comes with a man aboard and kyle seeger
gives the mariners an early two-nothing
lead in the first inning
joey gallo will lead things off in the
second inning against justin dunn
oh this ball absolutely crushed down the
right field line is it fair
it is gone oh
just fair
a good 600 feet away
my goodness that
was ridiculous over the storm trooper
out there
listen somebody was going to have to pay
for the joey gallo struggles here lately
and it was just and done and there was a
lot of aggression let out
on that pitch a quick put out of mar
maleo's
on one pitch
and now here comes shed long junior
breaking ball strike three called and
it's a one two three
for lyle's very sharp
take a look at the cg man himself marco
gonzalez mark how you doing man
oh
did you
did you calu i think you did you did
you dog
you dog we can't even get this interview
underway my guy's doing something
special
kyle lewis with his ninth home run of
the season
straight away center field and the
mariners lead the rangers by a score of
three to one what a freshman year in the
big leagues for kyle lewis holy smokes
that was something
now tavares he is fouled out in the
ground it up
there's a swing and there's a shot down
the right field line that's well hit and
that is history a line drive home run
for leote tavares
his second of the year
his second rbi and this is a one run
game seattle three and the rangers too
what a shout out he's had to work hard
this afternoon and to be honest with you
i wasn't sure that he was going to get
through five much let's get into the
sixth
swing and a miss
gallow down on strikes
fourth strikeout for justin dunn
two outs nobody out for trevino
dunn's 2-2
smoked
a pick there by france stays with it
nicely cleaned up on the other end from
evan white quality start today for
justin dunn
two runs over six ty france leads off in
the bottom of the sixth inning for
seattle
this one line back up the middle off of
lyles but behind him solac in position
to make the play and that is the old
one four three put out of ty france
one and two on seeger lyles pitch
breaking ball
sky to short center
coming on it is two in left center he
makes the catch a one two three inning
for jordan lyle top of the order tavares
he clocks this out towards the gap kyle
lewis can't get to it this is trouble
dietrich flying around he's hit in the
back at third he's being waved in
crawford up throwing coming to the plate
it's in time tag is down and they got
him dead to rights at home
lewis to crawford to odom and the
mariners keep a one-run lead take a look
at this slide he's standing up a little
bit high
a terrific relay play by the mariners
outstanding
jordan lyles has been able to steady the
ship
on base with a one-out walk
dylan moore going to pinch run there
goes dylan
headlong slide and dylan moore is safe
at second base
brett martin will take over this will be
his eighth appearance
on the ground into right field for a
base hit dylan moore steaming around
here comes the throw home up the line
dylan avoids it he's safe
little reroute there for dylan moore
gets across the dish it's a two run lead
a run on the board but more importantly
the bases are loaded so this is a huge
part of the game right now and for brett
martin going up against the right-handed
hitting ty france
and that ball is hit on the left side to
his left kind of philetha he scoops it
throws across the diamond in time to get
france for the final out in the inning
two down for evan white he's over three
this one lifted out to center field
tavares is back near the wall it will
make the catch that a boy
leote
with a little something
and we'll go to the ninth inning
hirano takes over in the ninth to try to
lock this one down
kuzman the hitter and he'll take 2-2
pitch boy that ball well struck deep out
to right it is gone
way up there by the cafe
a solo blast by guzman and it's a
one-run game
last hope for the rangers
anderson tejada the one-two swing and a
miss for strike three and the ball game
was over the mariners hang on and they
win it
a final score of 4-3 the mariners have
won five in a row
and they've taken 10 of their last 13.